join my day Joe Rogan podcast one night
all day t-mobile arena remover
Mayweather McGregor yeah good googly
moogly [ __ ] can happen and how is that
going to happen
what do you mean how you see do you
think the UFC and Mayweather come to an
agreement yes that's what's happening
Conor over in Vegas is in cahoots with
the UFC let's get this I guarantee
you'll see involved but the report who
knows who made that report pretty good
you might hit it on the way over here I
made up I might have I think it can it
happen man wow you really think so I
really do and you're asking me contain
it so let's just figure this out now you
want to talk to you just head we don't
and probably companion on me I don't
know man I don't know what I'm doing
well if you're not commenting me you're
like giant companion for it and yeah
that was elebrate the [ __ ] out of it I
would prefer that honestly June 10 June
10th is out to get me a lot of my man
Mayweather so she done TMT money hmm I
don't think they really care about me
commentating they'd probably want Max
Kellerman or the boxing people that Max
come in you would be fun I would love to
do it with them but that's what that's a
boxing match you know that's their world
yes I mean if it was a minor zone and he
was sitting down next to me doing
commentary you know that I think that
would be a little odd to not it not a
Floyd was just doing boxing the Octagon
you know say the negative ion well no no
I'm saying if the roles were reversed
like I think there you could talk about
moving Connors history because they've
been under oh [ __ ] let's be right
they're gonna be like you know she and
sharp talking about UFC it's where I
have to listen to it's going to be good
at someone who's knowledgeable break
down like Connors history how he came
here I got his movement was known for I
think that's super important you have
tougher people who don't watch you and
me yeah you're drinking a shitload of
new boxing you come together and then
hanging out with you guys smoking weed
watching it right here though so much
better
I just want my dear friend Joe Rosen
part of the biggest fight of combat I'm
good
I'd like to be a big key right here
crazy jumping is the biggest sign is a
lot of you think financially bigger than
money
Frazier nonetheless yeah yeah it's a big
biggest pay-per-view ever because it
brings in two worlds it brings in the
UFC world and this one guy was
unquestionably the biggest star in the
UFC unquestionably by a longshot and
then you bring in a guy who has been one
of the biggest moneymakers in the
history of boxing change begins the only
got to go 49 I know of in Rocky Marciano
I mean he's like right there and we'd
love to break rocky Marciano's record
and then you know one man when people
want to do things like break someone's
record and you want to do it so bad they
take on a guy who's never had a boxing
match before and then that guy starches
you this is killer I mean it's not like
I said I'm gonna build as you try to him
crater with everything some about you
guys I don't know man I'm telling you
this something about that dude he's got
something going on magic he's got a
little something extra special but he
would need he would need everything to
line up it would have to be the McGregor
or it may whether would have to dismiss
him as a threat
he'd have to not train hard enough he'd
have to not seriously consider the
possibility Conor connects on him an ox
mouth right and then Conor would have to
do some roughhousing he'd have to hold
it in middle energy yeah he'd have to
hold him and hit him he'd have to try to
get off as many shots and bully him
around and wear him out the possibility
it's a possibility he's a mighty with a
your mask he's a much bigger probably
very very quick but if you compare the
two of them frame wise like what if they
ever do do it and they're standing right
at each other looking down at each other
you know do an eye-to-eye you're going
to go oh [ __ ] jack on his way because
remember when Eddie Alvarez was going
eye to eye with Conor you realize how
big Connors head is like Jesus overall
just a bigger dude their shoulders his
legs that's a big [ __ ] I mean he could
make that 145 pound cut when he's on
death's door but Mayweather makes it
easy what are they gonna fight at 45
that's a good question
no maybe was fighting in 154 ft floor so
I bet they do it like 55 hit 60 maybe
maybe depends on what may was
comfortable with it but but I think the
end day in a white you want to be part
of that fight if you're doing what you
want be cahoots with all these guys with
Mayweather
Floyd or I don't want to fight to take
place at all and look he's got big on
buck because nurmagomedov got sick
making that wait if member gomad off
didn't get sick making that weight then
nurmagomedov Tony Ferguson Dana White
did oh they're like understudy Connor
didn't know DFC did because look the
real fight is the winner of Tony
Ferguson and Habib number Camaro in the
UFC right so that's the real fight as
like being a big challenge for Conor and
that could be a million plus papers I'm
curious right especially if you if you
either have that fight or the better
fight financially is another fight with
an idea
no the better fight finances Mae West oh
yeah for Bob Knight no no for John same
for Conor enough for sure for sure Conor
as a business that's by far the 100%
agree degrees without saying in 20
million way more than all squatters
hundred mill hotter five hundred 100
million annoyed to rayborn's good find
uh he's so fast
[Applause]
[Music]